thank you
hello Auntie
he's a bit spooked this glorious day
best day
stroke this big dick till he calms once
almost there
what a miraculous day the Lord hath made
let us be glad and rejoiced for he is
inside all of us
Noah how are you now Noah worse off than
the next guy I suppose
Daniel haven't seen Yee in the age of a
dog once yep
Daryl what can we do for you
when your community has always used us
right hopefully you feel as though we
used you right
once now you've said it at least twice
twice once at least twice at least twice
once yeah twice or more not once or
twice once at least twice twice or more
ones can confirm Wayne you've been a
great friend unto me for many years now
okay for banging the boxes summer last I
feel the great need deep within me to
repay you for the kindnesses shown the
very best way I know how well here we go
well how's that with a sausage party
wait first a box hammer and now a witch
a sausage party
well he must mean literally I've spent
the majority of mine adult life stuffing
my meat into casings it's thrilling work
rewarding and exhausting yet I won't
rest until my sausage has touched the
back of your throats well I do love
sausages me too like I love it so much
I feel a bit better if we could bring a
date ah I'm afraid there's only one rule
of a sausage party no women allowed oh
okay so he meant literally as well as
figuratively are your daughter's gonna
be around not today they're having a
party with mine wife in our very own
kitchen that's a good thing besides a
sausage party has a good chance for men
to blow
off a little steam
yeah I'm not sure we can make it though
Daryl you silly Gosling I haven't even
said what it is right shoot it's Duty
will be there I love sausages me too
like it's so good
what goes on a sausage party a barrel it
sounds like it's a party's where guys
eats a lot of sausages like literally
the sausages parties but also it's a
Dudes Only party so figuratively if the
sausages parties as well
Daniel I must confess you art testing
the limits of my one-room schoolhouse
education with all those fancy words
I know that Mennonites aren't exactly
known for having a wagon load of gray
matter the can they run still I do
wish I could give mine children Great
Brain
alas it's of no matter so what sayeth ye
I won't take Noah
for an answer so no daughters no not on
this day what about sisters Daniel time
will tell by the looks of the Sun
it's fast approaching noon it's 3 P.M
I'd best get home to prepare
it's as much for your benefit as mine
for ye haven't truly lived
until you've had dick meat in your mouth
foreign
[Music]